before we move on to any of this other
stuff I just want to make this quick
word about bless you proof is one of the
most amazing things in maths are in fact
it's one of the only things that really
only exists in maths and nothing else I
want you to consider is where proof
right what does it mean to prove
something you something has been proven
so I'm put the hand I'm told what's like
a phrase or a would a substitute that
would mean the same thing but not yeah
fantastic oh you put that in his logic
right and let me say that phrasing at in
case you didn't catch it it's how you
know something is right absolute that we
might take true shade you want to office
is all good there's logic is evidence
right that's how you prove something
isn't it Richard wanna add one more
thing yeah expert absolutely Oh sources
are where you get the evidence from
right now okay think about all of the
places and times where proof is an idea
um when I you proof and I hear evidence
the first place my mind goes use like
interesting enough the first place my
mind goes is a law court it's like okay
you know ah Lord Lord I it's like okay
we've we've seen all the witnesses we've
grabbed at all the evidence we used all
that logic and we've proven
such-and-such a person's gives you in a
circle Sam at night okay I'm you might
have also heard this word connected with
likes a science it's been scientifically
proven that bubble up here's the
interesting thing right in a law court
and in science right poof kind of it
usually means right or true but kind of
right because for instance you guys know
there are loads and loads of cases of
things that are proven in a law caught
by lawyers and people with lots of money
lots of evidence but then it's like oh
sorry guys it was it's over rule because
it's not it's not true it's like we've
actually found other evidence that
conflicts with what we said before sorry
we said he was guilty he's
innocent and he gets you to exonerate
and so on I in the same way in science
we prove things but science makes
progress right science changes it's like
you know you guys have seen this if I
draw this hopefully you kind of
recognize what this is supposed to be
right yeah you think oh that's an atom
right except science has proven that
actually that's nothing like what it
Adam really looks like it kind of gets
at the basic idea but we have learned
something far more profound right we we
saw alluded to this beginning geometry
so in science and law at it worse other
fields perf means kinda proven but in
maths maths when you prove something
it's really really true there's no kind
of to proof in mass it's absolutely true
it's always true you ever i showed you
all those names from the beginning is
topic right all these like you could
love a chair ski nice lady etc once you
prove something in maths it's true
forever ah well yes but we didn't know
it we didn't know that it was true and
now we do and now you know that's why we
can study things that were established
in 300 BC and they are timeless and
still just as true so the things we've
been learning if you remember from last
less than we look through these out all
these different kinds of quadrilaterals
and how they how they evolve and we
learn all these properties that the
quadrilaterals have okay now here's what
I'd like you to first thing underneath
this up anyway the point of learning all
these properties the point of learning
is not just like so you can save them so
you can recite them right so you can say
oh there are two pairs of adjacent equal
sides of the kite that's not the point
at all the point of learning properties
is so you can use
to prove it that's why I kind of went on
about proof right we said that are you
guys mentioned logic and evidence are
kind of like the pieces that you put
into a proof and properties of shapes
are kind of like logic and evidence
thrown together right